when the cookies too small for the tiny
mill : you don't want to break it in
half cuz that's not how you eat a cookie
or when your pizza rolls puke their
little guts out in the oven I don't even
want to talk about this one I don't know
what I hate more than the stupid cord
and it happens way too often to be an
accident it's a conspiracy when it says
perforated but really means partially
perforated tear at your own risk stupid
perforation or when you get sexually
harassed by a doorknob or when an
airplane armrest tries to steal your bag
while you're walking down the aisle when
the only way to get the toothpaste you
paid for is to torture the tube until
the alien blood comes out when the
underneath of your fingernail waives a
surrender flag made out of pain and
cringed nasty make it stop when your
hands feel like giant hands or when it
won't stand straight with a spoon in it
when a book uses a movie poster as its
cover and your imagination is stuck with
some stupid actors face when a company
makes the web suck for an entire country
or when plug designers forget what an
outlet or power strip actually looks
like plug hog when people broadcast that
they're sad but then won't tell you why
or let you help or those crazy house
centipedes that you know are made out of
the mixture of dust and evil and try to
eat your toes when you sleep when a
pencil sharpener gets the sharpening
part right but forgets about the writing
part which is the point pun intended or
when your comfort in bed is it exactly
the same level as your urge to pee and
you're stuck in pee limbo when the
fitted sheet doesn't fit and you have to
touch the weird bed fabric and wrestle
with the sheet tangle
well when YouTube does this even though
it says that it's buffered WTF YT when a
milk carton makes you feel like an
incompetent idiot with the ripping and
the trying the wrong side and the torn
edges when the binder rings don't even
come close and turning a pages like some
crappy physics puzzle and then I get all
bothered that I even get bothered by
these things I don't know what's your
peeve